la russie va lentement ce week-end sa
campagne de vaccination contre le coc
vide 19 son vaccin spoutnik v a été
distribué à travers 70 clinique un sujet
est signée ioulia chapeau bas loire et l
aide masquelier nous nous trouvons dans
les locaux de la société bio cad à saint
pétersbourg c'est l'un des laboratoires
qui a signé un contrat avec le
gouvernement pour produire le premier
vaccin anti qu'ovide enregistrés en
russie
le spoutnik v sa production à grande
échelle a déjà commencé venez voir
spoutnik v est un vaccin à deux doses
utilisant des adénovirus comme vecteur
vous en avez peut-être déjà entendu
parler à la différence de certains
autres vaccins anti coville 19
internationaux les vecteurs de spoutnik
v ont recours à des adénovirus d'origine
humaine et non animale mais qu'est ce
qu'un vecteur au juste il s'agit d'un
virus modifiés dépourvu de gênes de
reproduction et donc un capable
d'infecter ce qu'il fait c'est servir de
véhicule pour les protéines du coc vide
pendant trois semaines un patient va
recevoir deux piqûres différentes pour
développer des anticorps et ainsi une
résistance à la maladie
le vaccin utilisé de 12 c'est un
processus assez complexe en terme de
production parce qu'il faut produire
deux vaccins et non pas un seul dans la
pièce derrière moi le vaccin est mis en
bouteille
ici il est emballé cette ligne
particulière est capable de produire
6000 bouteilles par heure soit trente
mille doses chaque bouteille contient
cinq doses destinées à autant de
personnes à vacciner chaque bouteille
contient cinq doses destinées à autant
de personnes à vacciner avant de se
faire vacciner chaque patient est
examinée pour s'assurer qu'il est en
bonne santé
il faut ensuite quinze minutes pour
décongeler le vaccin jusqu'où tu me
lever et stockés à -18 degrés celsius et
les développeurs affirment que c'est un
avantage par rapport au vaccin conçu par
d'autres pays qui exigent eux des
températures de stockage nettement
inférieur
après injection les médecins vous
gardent sous surveillance pendant 30
minutes avant de vous laisser repartir
je travaille dans l'éducation et je suis
en contact direct avec les enfants
enseigne la chorégraphie par conséquent
je ne peux pas garder mes distances avec
les enfants comme c'est le cas pour
d'autres enseignants il est une
communication tactile avec les enfants
pour corriger tel ou tel mouvement
je pense que la vaccination est un
excellent moyen de me protéger et
surtout de protéger mes proches ou bien
encore mes parents qui ont plus de 65
ans contre ce virus
j'ai donc profité de cette opportunité
dès qu'elle s'est présentée j'ai été
examiné par un médecin il m'a demandé si
j'avais des maladies chroniques des
douleurs il a mesuré ma pression
artérielle consulter mon dossier médical
électronique
puisqu'il n'y avait aucune
contre-indication j'ai été autorisé à me
soumettre à la procédure
tout s'est déroulé très rapidement j'ai
d'abord reçu un message qui indiquait
que je pouvais être vaccinés je suis
vraiment heureux d'avoir une telle
opportunité parce que cela me donne la
possibilité de me protéger contre toute
nouvelle infection encore anna virus
j'avais des doutes mais j'ai pris une
décision et me voilà d'ici aujourd'hui
le vaccin est distribué aux quatre coins
du pays
en même temps les militaires eux aussi
reçoivent le spoutnik v en russie la
vaccination contre le coc vide 19 et
volontaire et gratuite
et bien que certaines personnes soient
encore sceptique sur la sécurité et
l'efficacité du vaccin
la plupart s'accordent à dire que seule
la vaccination à grande échelle
permettra de mettre fin à la pandémie